Jason's group and we were gonna jump for
your group so I'm going to start off by
or Wegener start with some background
material I'm gonna talk about a concrete
or group phase and we're going to
introduce some notions of thickness and
divergence which we study a lot with
summer
Robbie's then going to talk about some
algorithms that he worked on to
determine upper bounds on thickness and
I finally thought about Miyoung we're
going to talk about random graphs and
what happens at constant probability
densities so I'm going to start off by
defining a right-angle coxeter group so
given any finance official graph say
gamma the right angle positive group
associated with it he is the group where
the vertices of gamma first wanted
generators in the group each of the
generators has ordered two and in Ag
between two vertices generators
signifies commutative relationship and
up to the absence of an ng-click no
relationship so there is an example so
we have the
that usual group there so we have two
generators and there's no relationship
between them so you sort of get these
Infinity Ward legs so if you have
degenerates and B since there's a
relationship between that you can sort
of start getting a B a B and you could
sort of have this amazing network
similarly if you look at this which is
about two generators and they commute
with each other you get nothing but the
claim for group and then this is just a
direct product of two of these same
infinite legs these are just some basic
examples of right ankle cognitive roots
I am now gonna let me talk a little bit
about Davis complex divergence and I'll
come back and there's a few comments
associated to that and it's called the
Davis complex
the one Staunton is acutely cap porcine
to that
PFF is just presentation of a group
where from each vertex because
essentially I just come along
the rest of the Davis bucks reach me
self-government and courtesies in their
back you have the chorus on the empty so
for example if you have an edge
connecting two vertices then you can so
um nestled define that merchants what
they're virgins basically is is a
function that describes the would impact
in the space for example if you if you
wanted if for example in how to if you
want to take the ball I may be of some
given radius and you want to cut it out
of the divergence will describe the way
to cut that ball
um so I was in her too we never just a
Bolivia because well they didn't produce
around several circles just
so here's the example actually Gotha are
saying I would
sighs oh so this is just
Pakeha associate mrs. Pagett imagine
torture if you build the game is compact
so nervous it just looks like it's
little bit of squares so this has no
choice because
so here's another example public graph
this is less effective on located of
course like this economy is as as
concedes that
right so for me here so in particular
dependent beverages in these tiny spaces
is hyperbolic on which basically means
that that evidence is founded by the
virtual function so here's a picture by
a Pepsi lecture which I solutions as you
can see as you increase the radius so in
context of possible subunit only want to
use divergence to study at a metric
invariant completeness on it's fluid
thickness of order zero in the Indigo is
responsible in here that they're just
so when we who use the particular
gardens around in Cygnus and about zero
six five ridges
so this meetup gave us sort of an idea
of how to understand thickness through
divergence so we're going to give us
slightly different notion of sickness so
if you look at any finitely generated
group G we say that it's algebraically
thick of order at most n if we can find
this collection script age of bossy
isometrically embedded subgroups that
satisfy certain conditions so
effectively what we want is that if we
take the union of all these each in in
script age we generate the entire G
we've got some finite index subgroup of
it
then we want each of the bossiest
perfectly but it's subgroups to be
themselves the order it was n minus 1
and then finally if you take any to be
was a semantically valid subgroups age H
prime we want to have this sort of
sequence of H is such that the
intersection of any two consecutive ones
is of finite order or certificate or
exceeding so that's what a slightly
different position about thicknesses and
that gives us know that something is
thick of the order at most N and if we
also say I know that it's not like the
border at most n minus 1 that's sort of
how we can get a precise precise
thickness so that's anyway sort of what
we work on a lot this summer and so sort
of to start off I'm going to talk about
a couple of basic algorithms that we use
in
method of use-apply clemency close quest
to get the exact thickness for piss-poor
zero and then I'm gonna talk about this
for one so we have this theorem that
thickness of order zero which is gonna
said basically having linear divergence
is equivalent to being a direct 100 to
infinite subgroups or that's equivalent
to be to the graph it's even join and
join the as long as it's not joining too
quick but effectively it was that
problem was down to checking whether a
graph is a joint so this is sort of very
basic algorithm that we I mean it's just
to check whether to go or whether graph
is a joint that we implemented
effectively what you're trying to do is
you start with the vertex and then you
keep track of all other vertices that
must be in the same component so if you
have worked X every vertex as every
other vertex it's not connected to it
must be in the same joint component so
you start with a vertex B and you add it
to this list Cal and then keep adding
all these other vertices that must be in
the same denied components which starts
with all the vertices that are not
connected to B and then you keep going
tonight you have say you have five you
were to see there you check each of
those and add all the vertices that are
connected to those who are sort of
building up this one joint component
you're using a logic that it's in the
same joint component for sure if it's
not connected and so you sort of build
up this list L and then finally when you
can no longer add vertices to how we
look at L and you say okay if now I have
all the vertices that have been added L
they're all in the same joint component
and therefore the graphs not really
joints they all have
the same component whereas if you have
sort of you just sort of you know some
set of vertices in a you know that your
graph wasn't going to where it was
that's one component than the remainder
so this is sort of a basic algorithm to
just to look at whether a graph is big
order to Darrow and similarly sort of
whoever this by this condition I like to
see a best condition which stands for a
component full support that came from
paper by dhania Thomas that we sort of
used and again implemented using both
legs and I suppose Buster with various
different conditions and so the idea
behind this is you look at the graph of
gamma of the coxeter group and you
generate a new graph which is known as
gala for and it's basically what's
called The Associated for cycle graph
which basically you take all the four
cycles and galaxies look at all the
squares in gamma and each of those
become vertices in gamma four and you
connect two of these vertices in gamma 4
if the two squares in gamma shared two
edges or share it with you so that's
sort of looking at these squares and
then you generate this this graph based
on overlapping squares and then finally
we would give you to look at this graph
when you try and find the component of
the graph which is a connected component
and what's known as it has full support
so what that means is that the component
gal4 if you look at that component then
the associated vertices back again
though you cover all of gamma so your
connected component gamma 4 and then the
associate vertices give you all again
what's known as opponent with full
support and that's sort of tells you
whether Iran and you also obviously
matrix not a joint so it's not taking
orders gyro and therefore staple order
one so that's sort of what we spend a
lot of time on all right I'm excited
I've spent a lot of time on this
implementing this and then I mean this
going to talk about some examples and
then after that all we will actually
talk about there those four higher
orders it because right at least getting
upper they found us because if that's
where they can get that sharp upper and
lower thickness so they make specifics
they started building up the most fair
which is the border zero to join and
they and
so for this kind of death but the goose
is about through by distinguishes origin
- OH
our city surveillance particular one
starting with this this would be labeled
B zero so this would be big of order
five so what we were you know one of the
things was to try to understand and
modify that Orion see
so for example if you add its edge
in the bottom this reduces their keys
from order six to order to five so the
order of thickness goes down that one
it's because you can see those there's
this uh breath inside it which has
Milberg is it not always true this just
happens because with specific graph if
you like go to the deepness complex you
can sort of force any path and whatever
enlarger got to go Buddhist but one of
the things you're still working on is
how to generalize
okay so this is one above okay
really so we can get an up-or-down get a
rule about
it means but they are is not exactly so
or working not talking about I tried to
get
so at the start of the summer we have
this theorem by document system which
says that
WMS think of support if and only if
gamma can be formed by thinking thick
unions and coating so what does that
mean
so if you start with graphs
both of these are gonna be second
quarters here because their joins
between the vertical literacy sort of
for example their disease language for
that's when you could take their stick
Union so they're thick rats and if they
share a subgraph rules say that this
square and that's where is obviously not
a clique because it's missing for
example this edge and this edge a graph
gamma formed by taking both of them
together and arbitrarily any edges
between three times you could connect
this vertex and this vertex because
they're not in the overlap the graph
that you get
it's called a thick union of little dose
graphs and to prove that in spec you can
take each of these sub graphs to be
correspond to your subgroups and the
requirement that their overlap is not
afflict ensures that their intersection
is infinite you can also come so if
gamma is a thick graft
with the sub graph the lambda which is
onclick and lambda here's can be this
vertex and this vertex the graph gamma
prime formed by adding a new vertex B
this one
and it heads between me and every vertex
is that cuts up here and here we say
that general prime this new graph is
formed by pointing off lambda and this
turns out to be actually one of really
close to one of the Donnie Thomas graphs
that's how those reformed that's also I
guess another proof of why detective
Sommer and so a theorem that I drew is
that coding you can cone off not just
one vertex we can come off an entire
clip for example this is a little
triangle and you only go up sickness by
order at most one so if gamma not this
little surly thing is a crafter's
corresponding right an imposter group is
think of somewhere N and lambdas I
clicked with K vertices and each of them
is combed off on some diameter - I ain't
not complete or not click sub graph then
the resulting graph gamma corresponds to
a group that is thick 1/4 at most n plus
1 and it turns out that the collection
that demonstrates this is the set of
conjugates of the original graph WM by
all combinations possibly of any
generator in lambda so though so if you
have K vertices that will be
the combinations including as you can
see me but the one with none and the the
really interesting part of this proof is
just so that you can get a finite index
subgraph of our finite index subgroups
are of the entire graph and what you do
is you find a some workers of B from the
V gamma to the CNC to the K or the Z to
Z star to the a see what you see and in
fact the kernel of this homomorphism is
any word that has an even number of the
generators that are in this clip and it
turns out that the like condition that
you have an even number of that is
precisely what you need to ensure that
it can be built up of these confidence
so the plan what we know from here and
similarly you can also show that you can
take any number of unions at one step at
once as long as they each intersect so a
plan both of these we get a few
algorithms that can give you a upper
Batmen thickness the first one you
alternate unions and cones
so you start out by you start out
actually by a building of script n which
is a collection of maximal thick joint
sub groups or sub graphs right brother
so for this craft in particular the
maximum join some groups that are brass
sorry letter to stick are gonna be these
two and you start out with sickness T
equals zero and then in the in
alternating medium some cones use first
check whether gamma is the in script M
for this crap is not and then next you
take unions in across script and so that
in the result you get every end script
and just like the order it was T plus 1
so in that in here it would be you take
the union of these two and you get
everything like this for next trigger so
then you check on their end page if yes
then you you say what we've got at least
or at most sorry one more quarter of
thickness and you check if gavest in and
again and again here it's not so here
you would check you then co-team the
biggest possible click which is actually
just this graph at this vertex to each
mm so that each M&M is thick or at most
again T plus one and you check out there
and change again it did so then we say
isn't T is then it goes up by one and
your peak from step one where here we
would check whether gammas and then and
in fact it is so this first algorithm
tells us that our upper bound is two for
this graph and then you continue going
if you haven't did not change em twice
than you report fanship if you don't
have amend another algorithm that I
wrote thinking that it would actually
give a like a lower number because it
seems like you can get more from taking
a bunch of unions at once rather than
doing a bunch of coding is you taking
news until you can't anymore and then
code and in fact both the the algorithm
is code inside for this graph doable to
give to it turns out to be the neither
out where that was optimal for example
sometimes they'll give to when the
answers actually one but they and
neither of them consistently
lower number than the other in fact the
a/v union's one where I thought the
union's on would always but their eyes
on the graph that gives this one gives
45 there's some usage however in
practice they've been surprisingly
effective and they've allowed us to
grasp things so here is a movie that we
made and what it shows you is as the
density of a given number of random
graphs that we've generated increases
you sort of see how the the program
estimates thickness that were like kind
of over time surprisingly as you
increase either the number of vertices
or the density to a certain regime you
get a thickness of word one almost
always also interestingly the program
slows way down
I've written Pascal but it slows way
down when the answer is going to be one
there we go so I know the other thing
that we did was have the program should
have stopped once 10% 50% from 90% of
the graph so that was finding on I think
four before we were using 50 graph
samples and give reusing 10 to stop when
it would 10% to be percent to 90 percent
whereas they ordered one and you can see
as the density decreases the number of
vertices needed to get to these regimes
increases it seems super linearly and
I'll turn it over to harvester but I am
basically generalizing the result that
was various and I'll start with talking
about the construction of
so basically to construct a random graph
what we do is we first fix the number of
vertices let's say we have four vertices
and then for every possible edge with a
sign of probability that we have and
this is the model by tradition many so
the important things here that this
graph is first of all simple and
secondly one directed under it means
that the edges don't have directions
it's X the simple means that there are
there's at most one edge between two
vertices and there are no salt and while
constructing this graph
the way we do it is we fix a certain
probability P for every edge and the P
is sort of constant in the sense that
the probability of having an edge
between these two versus the same as the
timing abilities or any other so we're
not doing something like this edges
relative began this one like each of the
answers it's all the constant and
secondly the speeds independent of the
number of edges so just because there
are two edges here does not mean that
the probability of a prodigy will
decrease
and the second concept we require is
something called asymptotically Amish
fairly so we're investigating thickness
of random graphs and the way we look at
thickness is so consequently
asymptotically almost surely take so
first I'll define that almost surely
means if we take any sample space and
want to see the probability of an event
occurring almost here that just means
that a large set of measure 0 which for
example as I say we have a line which
covers both ends so if we remove a few
points here and there the quality of
selecting something from the line would
still be wonder if it almost surely one
because we may not get those points but
the problems you'll get many of those
points would be
and asymptotically almost surely means
that we're getting the results almost
surely but as I mentioned we fix the
number of vertices n but now we get that
the amplitude thing so that's that's
implying the result that was talking
about but thickness is here this is a
paper by a professor and two other
professors marking anomalous under
system where they prove that at constant
probability half the broth is asymptotic
we almost everything and we're looking
to generalize this so the reason that
people's 1/2 isn't easy poverty to use
improving this is the 1/2 equals 1 minus
1/2 so when you take the binomial
distribution a lot of simple a lot of
some of these things simplify and it
gets rid of the need for
not an extra fact is that we have to
introduce so this is the some years I
would try to generalize the the result
to a more generally and we proved it for
so I couldn't prove for all P but we
proved it for this range you should know
that each and so the proof to prove this
we took the original proof in the
analysis paper which is about like four
pages on and so this limit here so we
posted some other grounds for I go in
and we have this function f of N and we
prove that it's some who and using so
using those three results we get call
this number alpha and then we need to
find we need to prove that F of 18 will
be less than or equal to alpha minus
alpha squared so this is this is alpha
minus alpha squared for various
probabilities various numbers of noisy's
so nine took like
so what this the data this is using is
the number of the graphs the total
number of the craftsman n vertices and
also the total number of clicks in those
thick raps so if the nine that took
about two days to compute for ten it
would be in completely long time so we
on news 9 and you see here that's four
above above point four eight this number
is greater than zero below that it's
listed there so it's and so the rate we
proved it for was most of this range
that's about four three
six something so since that's where we
proved that his asymptotes evil we shall
be sick for
yeah
yeah thanks for listening these fun
things opportunity to thank our
professor we're talking RTA's and and
and also thanks we are you
goodness if any other foods besides
constituents
yes or we began by setting it for right
angled partners in fact every right in
our group is either hyperbolic or at
second supporters here over one which is
why it considers or yours because that's
not vacation